I so want people to see me as someone
who produces as somebody who's smart as
somebody who's hard working that I'm
ignoring signs of exhaustion
failure is the key to everything you
want oh yeah
I believe that yeah
I think it is
um
underrated failure I think failure is so
underrated people like especially to
myself like I'm someone who who was
always very afraid of failure who's
always afraid of looking bad looking
dumb I always wanted to like not ruffle
any feathers just be perfect
um and you don't learn anything from
that all you learn is to be more rigid
all you learn is to
seek more Perfection and more you know
whatever it is that more safety I think
you're seeking more safety
um in not messing up and not making
mistakes but all of the lessons are in
Failure everything is there every all
the information is in Failure even in
starting working writer I've had so many
like failures starting working writer
and so much to learn and like
you know whether it's like struggling
having to realize that I'm gonna have to
put myself out there if I want to make
this successful because people need to
know about it you know and like
and not doing that for the first year
and then like what you know almost being
like should I even continue this like
that felt like a failure almost
um but if I didn't have that experience
of
not getting any sales for the working
writer course because I'm not putting
myself out there I wouldn't have had to
put myself out there like all the
information is in
things not working
um it also I think is
necessary for our minds because I think
that like our minds are
our minds work in a way that like I
think our minds crave fixing especially
as a writer like I feel like uh my mind
likes puzzles my mind likes to figure
things out and instead of seeing that
failure the first year of working writer
as a death sentence or as a personal you
know
um
comment on my own ability I could see it
as something that was beckoning me to
grow to open up to be in front now I'm
like oh I'm so glad that that happened
because it's led me here to you guys so
it's just like I just think that um
I just think that failure is something
if you're someone who is avoiding
failure if you're someone who's afraid
of failure failure definitely can
can suck it cannot feel great
um but
I think that
the best stuff is behind failure truly
it really is
success is awesome it it feels great but
you only get there through the failures
like there is no success without failure
and you might as well enjoy the process
enjoy the journey
you know take the failure as the very
fantastic
opportunity that it is to learn a lesson
to learn what you need to know
um there there's no other way to say it
it's like failure is not always fun but
it is necessary
what is failure exactly
I mean I think that there are very clear
ways to determine failure
for me for working writer it is for the
course it is being able to turn it into
a business for the podcast it's being
able to turn it into a business that is
profitable
um and in order to do that it has to be
valuable to people in order to do that
it has to bring value and so the way
that I recognize whether or not it is
succeeding is
the way that I recognize whether or not
it is succeeded succeeding in
being valuable to people is if it is
making a profit so if it's not making a
profit then something's wrong I'm
failing at giving value so
that to me is cut and dry like
if but if you don't get into let's say a
screenwriting competition or if you
don't win one or something like that
to me that is failure but
failure is information like once again
so what kind of information are you
getting are you getting information that
your writing wasn't up to Snuff as the
people as good as the people that did
win
um or is it just that these people were
just more original this year it it it's
still information ultimately so I guess
I I think the answer is failure is
information
we talked about wanting to be the
perfect student sitting in the front of
the class and and always wanting to do
the right thing do you think it
sometimes helps to have a chip on your
shoulder though I know that can be
looked at as to rebellious or or
negative but do you think it's a good
driver to really be like you know what
I'm so pissed right now and I'm gonna
prove that this is not the case
instead of being the perfect this is
like a little bit more of a messy
motivation I don't necessarily think
it's about like having a chip on your
shoulder but I definitely think it's
about
um
having a strong opinion having a point
of view you know like I think that you
the times that I have spoken up if I'm
against something or if um
I don't know I think the things that I
speak up the most about are about how I
think we should treat each other as a
society is how we should treat how we
should be how respectful we should be of
each other
as human beings and I don't think that
that's a chip I think that's like a
point of view that is something that I
deeply believe in what does it mean to
you to be perfect
um
now I think to be perfect is to be uh
overwhelmed now I have all kinds of
negative connotations with perfectionism
you know before I used to think it's
like about you know appearing
well whether that means what you're
wearing appearing as if nothing's wrong
in your life and everything's hunky-dory
but now I find perfectionism to be an
absolute trap I think perfectionism is
not good for our psyches I think it
overwhelms us I think it puts us in
um I think it puts us in a very
bad position
um to live
healthy lives so I I don't
I don't have a good I think
perfectionism is is overwhelm did you
see Ingrid Goes West yes okay yeah I
love that film I love that movie it is
so amazing because you have one
character whose life is a total train
wreck and is scrolling and thinks
that that is the goal right there and
it's just I mean it's a funny movie but
it's also a very sad movie because I
think it it happens a lot absolutely
it's one of the reasons why I try to
talk about my failures I try to talk
about perfectionism
uh because I just think that what we've
what we create with this perfectionism
uh box that we're putting everybody in
is
just a very restrictive
um a very restrictive life like we're
really restricting ourselves to what
life can look like and I just personally
don't have the desire or the energy to
live that way anymore
um I also think you know perfectionism
is a trauma response it can be a trauma
response uh I had a really bad burnout a
few years ago at the end of 2019 and
um I started just like a the nerd that I
am I started doing a lot of reading
about burnout I started trying to figure
out what was going on it's what led me
to radical acceptance by Tara Brock was
this burnout this this just
feeling that I you know
I couldn't do anything like when I was
burnt out I could not produce
and so it forced me to really face this
need to produce and this
um
this perfectionism that I have this like
deathly fear that I have of being seen
as someone who is weak or as dumb or as
lazy even though I am kind of lazy which
is fine
um I did not want anybody to perceive me
that way and ultimately that's a burnout
and the reading that I did I ended up
reading books like radical acceptance by
Tyra Brock I ended up reading not nice
by Aziz gazipura which is a great book
about self-compassion both of these
books are both about self-compassion and
both of them are about self-confidence
as well
um and then I read some other books and
one of the books I read I can't really
remember the name of it right now but it
basically talks about how perfectionism
is a trauma response it's something that
we do because perfectionism was what we
had to do when we were young to keep
ourselves safe whether it meant being
perfectly behaved for your parents
whether it meant like being the teachers
or and being the teacher's pet or
whatever it is that you had to do in
your life to overcompensate
um to be seen to to what for whatever it
is that you had to do
um and now in adulthood I'm I'm doing
the same thing and it's leading to
overwhelm I'm I'm such a perfectionist I
have such low self-worth that I so want
people to see me as someone who produces
as somebody who's smart as somebody
who's hard working that I'm ignoring
signs of exhaustion I'm ignoring
um I'm I'm like on this treadmill of
like non-stop work I'm ignoring my
personal connections my relationships
with my family and with my friends I'm
missing out on events on people's
weddings because I need to I I can't get
out of work I won't even ask to get out
of work because I'm afraid to ask to get
out of work because then I might get
fired like
um all and those are very real fears but
just the the exhaustion that Perfection
professionalism left to lead to and just
knowing that this striving is coming
from an emptiness it's coming from a
sadness it's coming from something that
needs to be healed from my earlier years
of just never feeling like enough and
like that burnout kind of forced me to
just sit and do nothing for like
two years I think it took me two years
to really feel like I could
do stuff again and it was a really
necessary time because with all this
unwinding of this perfectionism
I think you talked about it on one of
your podcasts with another fellow female
writer that I think you're doing a class
with and I think she talked about how
having it all actually felt very
stressful because now we're being given
these these images I mean I don't have
children but of of how to have it all
and you can be a mom you can do this and
it actually felt like oh my gosh this is
overwhelming this is not what I
envisioned it to be absolutely and I
think that having it all just looks very
different now like I think like
I think in in the past maybe having it
all didn't require
uh at least at least for women in
particular to be both career Juggernaut
and Mom
and both of these things are huge
Endeavors you know and we're human and
maybe some people can do it and and
that's great for them but it's
definitely not something that I think is
doable for everyone nor should everyone
be doing it I think it's the extremely
exhausting and it's very difficult and
but at the same time it's extremely
expensive to raise children right now so
you kind of have to both be working and
you kind of have to be a career
Juggernaut if you want to raise your
kids the kind of way that you want to
raise them with the things that you want
them to have or or to even afford the
things that you want to have like a
house in school and things like that so
it's like I think the United States in
particular makes it very difficult for
on women because women are always the
ones that have to be the caretakers of
the uh nuclear family the extended
family they I think that caretaking role
sometimes extends into the workplace for
a lot of women I've seen that a lot and
I'm just like I'm I've taken off that
hat
I'm not doing
I do I'll be like a man I'll do one
thing
um and and that's fine and that's enough
yeah I was watching some some different
videos about you know Mom influencers
and imagine that pressure because you're
doing all those things you've talked
about but then you also have to present
yourself online absolutely as if
everything's perfect and unfortunately
there's been some very sad stories where
it didn't end up that way for people and
just the pressure that we're all kind of
uh on and and one of the things I want
to ask you about is is how is it in the
entertainment industry when we're always
looking up we're always looking to level
up and it seems like we're never
actually happy with where we are oh my
God I literally was just having lunch
with one of my friends who just finished
like a Marvel movie a show I think she
just
and she's like but what about the next
thing I don't know what the next thing
is and I was just like
it's always going to be about the next
thing you know what I mean like who care
it doesn't matter about the next thing
like you've done amazing things and I
think that you know that's what our
industry perpetuates you know it
perpetuates that like you're only as
good as like
your last three projects are like what's
next on the Slate and I just think that
like
I just think we don't need to buy into
it so much I think it's hard not to buy
into it but I definitely think it is not
mentally healthy because then we don't
celebrate our wins we don't actually
enjoy the success that we have and I'm
guilty of this too I'm guilty of I could
have just finished you know a a I'm a
producer on a TV show and then the show
ends and then I'm like panicking like
what do I do next what's next
um and mind you I have money I have
savings and you know I've worked but you
know your reps are giving you pressure
like everybody's making you feel like
you have to have the next thing and I
really want to normalize breaks after
projects I think it's good to like
refill your cup after a project get to
bask in the experience in it in the
reality that I just did something really
really cool possibly something I never
thought I would get to do uh what a
fantastic experience and that be enough
and that be okay because I think even in
that podcast episode that we're talking
about she says something about like the
journey is all there is or something
like that or like the hustleness or
something like that it's just it just
never stops and it's like all I think
that this Obsession and this fear about
the future is
I just think it can like really kill the
present and I think that because we live
in kind of a fleeting Society where
everything goes by really really fast I
think it's like really important to
savor things and that includes
booking big jobs and being happy that
you booked it and that you got the
experience and not freaking out when it
ends even though that happens and that's
totally normal and that's totally fine
but I just think that celebrating our
wins is really important and I think
sometimes when we
let our Panic set in
um about the next thing it really robs
the present of joy of satisfaction of
contentment with where you are not where
you're gonna be and I just kind of think
that like no matter what I realized was
like no matter what level I got to
you know when I before I broke in I was
like I just want to break in and then
after I break broken I was like I just
want that next thing and like I just
want that next thing it doesn't ever go
away the only satisfaction you get is in
the doing in the present that striving
never goes away so I've had to just get
comfortable with that feeling of I don't
know what comes next but I know that I
did this and this was fantastic and I'm
going to be satisfied with that for now